de preocupación así catalogó la
organización mundial de la salud a la
nueva variante del coronavirus a la que
denominó omicron ya que el grupo de
asesoramiento técnico sobre la evolución
del virus se reunirá periódicamente
sobre o micros se necesitarán días o
semanas para que se lleven a cabo
algunos de estos estudios tan pronto
como tengamos más información la haremos
pública pero es importante saber que hay
muchas cosas que pueden hacer para
protegerse y proteger a sus seres
queridos aunque los estudios apenas
empiezan los expertos ya han alertado
sobre la posibilidad de que omicron
tenga una mayor transmisibilidad y la
capacidad de sortear la respuesta
inmunitaria de las vacunas tras el
anuncio la unióneuropea optó por
restringir viajes desde y hacia el
epicentro de la nueva variante todos los
vuelos a estos países deberán
suspenderse y se mantendrán suspendidos
hasta que exista un entendimiento claro
de los alcances de esta variante y los
viajeros que estén retornando desde
estas regiones deberán respetar
estrictas reglas de cuarentena sudáfrica
no demoró en reaccionar a la medida
catalogándola e injustificada
cosa que este es un mal enfoque está
equivocado va en contra de los
estándares de la o ms
we just simplemente tenemos la sensación
de que algunos líderes de países están
encontrando chivos expiatorios para
hacer frente a un problema mundial
en bélgica los laboratorios reportaron
el primer caso de contagio por la
variante sudafricana se trata de un
ciudadano que regreso de egipto el
pasado 11 de noviembre mientras que el
continente europeo enfrenta una de las
olas más fuertes